yeah a little welcome to a new video on
this will be part I think seven of the
e4 e5 repertoire series for black and
this will be about the scotch game which
is of course the position seen here
after 3d for on this video will be about
the line zone and the scotch which are
not the scotch for Knights yeah so we
won't look at this position here this
will be done in the next video I didn't
want to make this so long so I split it
up so this is so hard eight then to be
done very soon and now this part seven
deals with them the stuff rising here um
also I'll show you briefly what to do
against Bishop c4 which is also
sometimes played um this will be at the
end of the video
another alternative view will be c3
which after d5 transposes into this
Danish gambit I already did this in an
older earlier video so it's all about
takes Knight takes and here black has
some to main looks and one slightly
offbeat move on the two main moves are
Knight of 6 and Bishop c5 and according
to current theory they're both fine for
black but if you look at this you'll
notice that the very open position here
I mean d4 sort of the open game of the
open games it's really open and so there
are quite a number of possibilities
available for both sides after both
Bishop c5 and Knight f6 it's very
complicated and very tactical and I
didn't want to make it to our video on
the Scott
only so on I'm actually recommending the
move that I play myself at least then I
play it not all the time but at least
it's my favorite movement blitz and also
in tournament games I already tried it
out this is Bishop oops
Bishop to b4 check which um yeah looks a
bit weird at her side because it sort of
checks into thin air here but it's it's
quite quite an interesting remove and
attach they had got some nice points
first of all lets them get out of the
way what happens if white responds with
them uncommon moves
of course he needs to deal with the
check so what moves are they are then he
can play 93 which doesn't happen so
often curiously but it's not too bad
and then black had the chance of the
choice to go here which ins poses into
the Scotch for Knights to be shown in a
later video this is the young the sound
and solid choice black can also play
here which is quite interesting the idea
is quite simple this pawn is attacked
now and black will win this pawn I mean
this just wins upon but it is quite
risky I can show you a sample some
sample line one could take here takes
here now black cannot grab on g2 because
this here attack the Queen and then this
Knight can get out again and before it's
also hang so this is not working but
black hand of course simply recapture on
c6 for instance with the Queen here
castles and then Black has won a pawn
but it's a bit behind in development
it's playable
absolutely I have seen it played by a
grandmaster already and when I was was
actually playing the same
mentioned the Dutch league so it's
playable but it's a bit risky you can
play that if you feel like well I'll
take this and you show me if it's
working okay this is one possibility but
Knight f6 here as always a safe and
simple transposition and the bad move is
Bishop d2 is really bad Queen e7 now
sends white and so in two problems this
is just much worse than before
compared to 93 because now you force
hang the d 4s hanging and I mean here
like even as a choice you can grab a
pawn with this move or you can grab here
and win a pawn and this is just no
compensation
so Bishop d2 is just just bad but about
close to her now 99% of the time
c3 is played and then black retreats to
c5 and now you could ask what is the
idea of giving this check first and
after c3 dropping back when you could
have played Bishop c5 immediately one
move earlier and move four there is a
difference and the difference is that
now with a pawn on c3 white doesn't have
the general possibility to play Knight
c3 which very often is exactly on the
square where what's put night and now
there's a pawn there the clearest
example for this is if white takes here
which is actually the main line I would
show this in more detail later
like recaptures and in this this kind of
positions white really would like to
play Knight c3 at some point or at least
have the option to do so and now he
doesn't and this point somewhat hinders
his development very often he needs to
put the knight here or here and this is
not an ideal place so this is an extra
time before white but it's actually
debatable if it's useful so on this sum
is not the refutation Knight takes c6 I
mean the slide cannot be refuted to
anyway but
here c3 is no no big deal also one point
is white plays here black drops back and
in these kind of positions white also
would like to play Knight c3 Queen d3
and long Castle and he cannot because
this has a pollen c3 this point is
really am very often a nuisance for
white it's not a useful extremals so I'm
but let them get into the concrete lines
iam after Bishop c5 as I mentioned White
has quite some some options first let's
um look at some some really bad option
but which is uh nevertheless played once
in a while which is Knight f5 it's quite
a tempting move because this g7 poorness
attacked and this could actually be
quite interesting if black would need to
protect this pawn but as it turns out he
doesn't need to black has a very good
move here in d6 which simply attacks
this knight black would simply take it
if white does a neutral move here like
we should be three or something so wide
usually grab cm king of eight so it's a
gambit and now White has two
possibilities you can go here to h5 if
he goes here the black just captures and
goes Bishop Queen to h4 whether attack
on f2 and black also has got rook e8
coming and this is just a huge attack
notice the the huge needed development
black has got three pieces out in active
positions and black has got nothing
white has got nothing developed so this
is very fine for black m9 f5 is quite
bad this is somewhat better but still
very nice for black you have the some
Queen h4 move again and this also
threatens on f2 and this also so white
very much needs to retreat here nine f6
threatening here
so what let's here notice that Dwight is
can easily get completely thrashed if
he's got just one more inexact move
let's say here you already have stuff
like this coming up and like leg winds
instantly so it's already quite
dangerous so not f6 another six here and
then a move like ninety five to to renew
this idea to to go to G for black has
just a very nice position for the pawn I
mean usually white players get into this
by accident they don't put literally
want to get under an attack so ninety
five is so there's no thing to worry
about so on what else
white could certainly develop a piece
like here but then this doesn't threaten
how much like Knight f6 and you simply
continue developing with cancelling rook
to e8 stuff like this in this kind of
positions you really notice the pawn on
c3 is just just just badly placed white
would really like to play put a knight
on c3 also to control d5 but he cannot
very often you get stuff like this let's
say castles I mean maybe you could even
take here but this could be risky let's
say here here here and now it's already
bit ugly only 492 I can I can win a pawn
on d4 so black has no problems at all he
will just continue with the move of the
D pawn it developed further so um this
is pretty harmless stuff like Bishop to
c4 so the main moves by farm on I take
c6 and Bishop e3 so a knight X is six is
the main move so let's look at Bishop e3
of course now white threatens Knight
takes c6 so I move like this here oops
what would lose a piece so I need to be
cautious
what black is doing is simply retreating
to b6 where to Sir
posted nicely a.m. b6 so what should Y
do now the only move really pose posing
a problem is the Queen to g4 which is
circus power of invention you played
this first as far as I'm aware but let's
look at the quieter moves and one not so
quite move this analogy for a nod to f5
here this is a bit different because now
we have those blues bishop bishops
facing off each other so g6 is so d6 is
a bit questionable because white could
could for instance play something like
this here and now take and then you like
this attacking bishop on b6 this is not
so good in comparison so black play some
plays not d6 but g6 this is better so um
now what should why do if you just
retreats the default lost two moves g6
is not the greatest move in the world
but it's still the tempo so um yeah what
what should should be done here white um
doesn't have much better than capture on
on b6 here and then on return to e3
black then just develops some some
protecting move like Bishop d3 and
castles and now blacks idea is simply to
pay rupee aid and maybe d5 note that in
these kind of positions Knight c3 would
be a good move but white cannot cannot
move the Knight to c3 this pawn is just
just annoying hindrance IAM so it's not
not dangerous white could also go to c3
um and in
this position that's just one thing to
to remember that it is better not to
take only three but to continue
development here thing is if you take
only three which is not completely
terrible but I'll show you here I'm not
sure maybe here the idea is that white
might set up the position with c4 Knight
c3 and these kind of positions are still
okay for black but you'd rather have it
somewhat different like here here and
then if white takes at some point and
set up the same kind of structure then
it's quite nice to have the iPhone open
for some counter play so you just wait
until white captures on b6 also with
this capture on III and Knight takes c3
you help him strengthening the d5 point
you don't want to do that so just wait
until white captures himself okay this
is 93 c2 so Quincy form this was work
for a while considered to be a problem
for black but now it turns out that
black doesn't need to fear this move at
all
you even have a choice between an
aggressive continuation and a solid
continuation the aggressive continuation
is not F 6cm just sacrificing this pawn
so what grabs it not much choice choice
otherwise no G for the Queen g4 doesn't
make any sense
look here you just attack attack the
Queen constantly um and here black can
take on D form
I mean there are also alternatives yeah
but just I'm just showing one line here
if white would take with the bishop you
have this nice tactic with the idea
queen takes rook e6 and white resigns
and are not resigns maybe but close to
it you you're just in you travel on the
e-file so take here and then black can
can open up the position with them with
d5 and there are lots of little tricks
here based on the Queen and those
somewhat strangely play displaced pieces
I'm just showing a sample line here I
mean there alternatives but yeah black
just has a nice active position here and
most likely will get them get material
back for instance some moves a move like
here is quite a quite unpleasant to say
the least zone here here and this
conclude position actually is a draw by
repetition because you chase this Queen
eternally so this is an active
possibility and one where you could
easily find some some new ideas if you
if you analyze I think black is very
active but if you don't like this so
this is just too sharp for your taste
you can play the the standard move Queen
to f6 also then what goes here to get
out of this this discovery idea and here
in the in the original game which
Kasparov played the black play actually
decided to to grab this pawn which is I
mean risky and against Kasparov its
amounts to suicide so no good no good
idea to take this but you can simply
play this move and black doesn't have
any particular problems this position
might be slightly better for white but
even that I'm doubting really black can
just develop Knight to f6 or he six f6
looks looks a bit more or more active
Knight f6 d6 and so on just develop your
pieces one thing you need to be
aware of this kind of standoff of the
Queen's both sides don't really want to
take because it would open the H file so
it's an idea for black to wait until
Dwight maybe has cancelled so you but
you have some use for moves and I deaf
66 as I mentioned and you just wait
until castles and then you can even take
if you want so this is also a
possibility not not a big deal
so this whole Bishop III complex is not
too dangerous very often you can do with
just normal development and sensible
moves I think I'm the more dangerous
option here is for white to take here we
should be three this is some I think the
main test of black setup and here you
have a choice again here you can play a
sound in solid move or somewhat shaky
move let's say where you can set white
some concrete and not so easy to solve
problems but which is maybe a bit risky
and let's go for the safe and solid move
first this is a move like Knight d7 or
maybe also d6 it's these are very much
related let's say here the general idea
is that black now wants to complete its
development and intends to play castles
and then something like d6 and f5 or d5
according to to the circumstances I mean
this to the structure in general should
favor white slightly it's got a little
bit more space simpler development and
it's it's just a slight advantage for
white maybe but it's nothing that you
should be so usually afraid of if you
play before you fight this is a pretty
normal looking position and the more
interesting though is Queen h4
which is this is a move that I could
only recommend to to people who actually
willing to maybe do some analysis on
their own because it's really a tricky
yeah
tricky continuation it's a very good
move for blitz games because people are
very often a bit too quick with response
with their response IAM the the most
dangerous move by far here for blank is
Queen e2 and the thing is very often
people especially blitz games edges
Castle and after 90 f6 this is already
close to a quite dangerous attack for
black because this is somewhat crude now
g4 is a huge threat and this can easily
get get get ugly for white I mean just
just a sample just a sample line let's
say move like h3 here you can think
about okay and this is I didn't analyze
this before so if this is complete bogus
I'm sorry but just to just show one one
idea here if white takes now here I've
got this set up
or here and it's a complete mess but
it's most likely I mean Queenie - we
have Queen d2 as possible alright so I
didn't prepare this in detail before but
you see that there are lots of pieces
pointing towards the king and this d5
move is not mandatory you could just
play d6 frettin Bishop e3 or you can
also just castle so the castle here I'll
move April White is actually a bit meek
here at least maybe it's it's even bad
Queen e2 is a stronger move and we will
see why and yeah of course black wants
to develop his pieces so plays Knight f6
and here white White has a strong move
which is h3 and this shows them the
problem of this position because this
Queen here it looks very active on h4
but it also has quite a problem with
finding squares at the moment the Queen
doesn't have any square besides h5
everything else is controlled by white
pieces and you can see the consequence
and some if you look at for instance a
move like castle CM white goes to three
Queen here n g5 edgy form and now you
you really don't know what this what
this Queen is doing if if you go here
you even have to consider this with an D
F Knight f3 enters queen is trapped and
if you go into the middle of the board
and g5 is also a move that it's not to
welcome for black this night only has EA
there's a square and this already looks
like something has gone wrong like it's
just on the defensive here all this
stuff is getting pushed back so black is
a little bit playing with y and this
very
the move which might make this playable
and notice that I'm saying might because
this is just based on analysis and it
has never really tested in a game I mean
it has been tested in a game of mine but
it's not like there's a ton of theory
and this here this is the the problem of
d6 if why it doesn't go if I've black
has has no problem for instance let's
say here I can just capture and I think
just just cancel because it just helps
black that one pair of PSS he has been
exchanged so that screen is not not such
a huge problem anymore we should be
three is a bit lame though I mean the
real point is e five and here I actually
had this in the tournament game about a
year ago a little bit more and I was
working trying to figure this out at the
board and here made a major mistake
actually but it's it's difficult the
move that blacks should play as 95 what
I played is not good I could have easily
gotten a lost position I played 94 the
ideas that here takes here was check
black Ascot Bishop e6 and now I mean f2
is very much hanging so castles here
and now B should be six this is what I
saw in the game and I thought okay maybe
this is okay but white has got this very
annoying move and this actually leaves
black with the terrible position we
didn't reach this in the game you played
something else before because it didn't
see this move or maybe saw it but didn't
evaluate the consequences correctly and
this is terrible for black so you cannot
go on IG for as I did in the game but 95
and this is actually interesting in all
of a while to have something I think it
needs to grab this pawn yet with a check
after all yeah
what should plague do a lot much choice
I think he just needs to go here and now
black actually has got this red edge
that's this you threatened that you need
to attend to because you cannot
interpose on e3 our pieces are on there
so this is really a thing that one needs
to look at the best move has this castle
cm if white actually decides to grab the
pawn
this is questionable if now castles
black hand can even take here and it's
at least a draw with this kind of idea
so um here castles of the best smooth
and then black doesn't have much better
than then taking here then maybe can
Queen to f3 attacking f7 and keeping an
eye on the c6 born yeah and this kind of
position should be somewhat better for
white it's not so terrible at first I
thought this is really bad for black but
it's not entirely clear um
black can play rook e8 for instance and
it's not so not so not so obvious how
wide should continue here black still s
got some some tricks available let's say
white would take here then you can just
gain a temple and secure the King a bit
and you've got everything pointing
towards the king side it's pretty much
unclear maybe something to analyze but
here white of course has got multiple
possibilities you could also go here and
here directly attacking this formation
here black actually could go Knight
Queen to f6 and try to exchange Queens
which should be quite ok I mean this
position it's a bit shaky for black and
I would only advise to play it if you
have studied it a little bit more
I think it's playable it's um it's risky
though but you need to be aware that um
White has to play all those moves to get
there even this one notice if Y doesn't
go here he's got one alternative he
could also instead of playing 'if I've
played g3
and here and this is similar to what we
saw what we saw before the difference is
that this means now is just punished
with Bishop g4 so we cannot arrest the
Queen further and it actually ends up
with the Queen trade so why it takes
here and this position naam is GM
somewhere between equal and maybe a
little bit better for white but it's
nothing too too dramatic those the
little pawn moves yeah an advantage for
white if you manage to really set these
pawns into motion but it could also
easily be weakening F 3 H 3 and so on so
this is not too clear but it's playable
I mean one one general advantage of this
line compared to the the Scotch main
lines is that you can basically play a
game of chess from move on from 10
because it's not so theoretically um
well explored if you look a bit at this
yourself then you might have a really
really advantage over your opponent
because he doesn't know anything about
the line at all very often this is the
case even with strong players so this is
the difference to the main lines they're
often the theory really kicks off at
move 10 and here you can get along with
them somewhat less some learning effort
so yeah this is actually bishop before
check a pretty economic solution to the
to the Scotch opening which might be
compared to two main lines not 100%
equal compared to the main lines but
it's also much less work to invest and
very often you get your opponents by
surprise and
on yourself quite a nice position and
what I'd like to mention is that here
there's also another possibility which
is Bishop c4 I want to show this briefly
there's not much you need to know but it
happens him like has two moves as it's a
pole at his disposal disposal sorry
which is Knight f6 and Bishop to c5 hmm
and what you play there pretty much
depends on what you play on the Italian
game which which is this one which we
will look at later if you play this move
you can you need to study this position
which arises also on the other move
order and if you play the the regular
Italian game you need to play this
position as black and this also rises in
the other move runner so to make this
clear let's say here 96 we saw this
before it's the same as in the two nodes
but what I'm actually recommending is
Bishop c5 which is also my
recommendation against the Italian game
and this looks a very fine to me if
white now play c3 which is the best move
the knight f6 Justin supposes to the
regular Italian game and this is yeah
quite equal ish opening where black
doesn't have anything to fear at all so
no worries just the transposition and
the alternatives are not so great for
white he can castle which is the most
popular move and also this one has
sometimes played but this is nothing to
fear can even play lie to h6 covering f7
and if white snow goes into this typical
kind of operation here in this position
black actually has a very strong move in
d5 this can be easily missed so it's
good to to UM remember this idea
the ideas that this is actually really
bad check him and wookie five and black
gets back d5 which huge advantage his
King is much safer here then then
White's King and black ass got all these
pieces out so this is just bad for white
and if he takes with the Queen you can
exchange and play here getting something
like this which is also just better from
like so this whole operations with 95 is
not really good um usually what goes
here ro c3 c3 c3 being the best move but
this also possibility then you can play
d6 and this seems very nice for black
let's say c3 the only woolly to justify
this play then Bishop g4 is quite good
for black you are pinning the night so
that you actually protect the default
pawn and if white goes for some yeah
immediate attack on f7 you just ignore
this you can take here and this is very
nice very nice for black for instance if
it goes here you recapture here and now
black has a strong move which you really
should remember this g5 this is very
strong it just secures that the King
side stays permanently weak what cannot
go here form or something and black has
got ideas of Queen Queen shifts here not
here what we hear more to h6 on i2f form
something like this white King side is
just terribly weakened in this kind of
position you could easily imagine like
having enough compensation for opponent
here is not even a pond
so this is just just bad if wider
recaptures immediately then you have
also some some nicer possibilities um
for instance take here which brings this
idea into play so wider has not much
choice at one point he has to take here
Knight takes here here
attacking f3 and you can see that black
is just for Nia
he's got equal material and White's king
is just in a bit of trouble he's much
unsafe err compared to White's King so
this whole this whole line doesn't
really bring much for white so right
this was the scotch game the next video
as mentioned will be about the related
opening the Scotch for Knights and then
we'll switch to the to the Italian game
and yeah getting closer and closer to
the reuleaux pass at the end yeah thanks
for watching and looking forward to your
comments or questions on youtube thanks
for watching